it's great to welcome back to the
program bill scher who is contributing
editor to Politico magazine an ardent
follower of American politics as my
audience knows sometimes to their
pleasure sometimes to their displeasure
always good to talk to you bill
great talk to you too so I mean let's
just start with the simplest questions
first
Bernie Biden Warren does anybody else
have any shot at this point either in a
quantitatively defensible way or
qualitatively yes I think I think this
is right now a two-person race between
Ward and Biden real Bernie has had a
pretty rough couple weeks yeah and I
don't think that his medical emergency
means he can't be present that's not my
personal opinion and I don't know if
that's is the V reason why his numbers
are down past couple of polls but you
really see them being a much more of a
firm third place a position whereas the
last Quinnipiac poll was Warren 30 Biden
27 so you know they're the top two and
they represent clearly distinguished
ideological positions in the party
however I don't think either one of them
is wholly secure Biden as we know us has
had all sorts of problems I think less
ideological and more performance-based
yes and if he continues to not seem
sharp on the stump admit he won't grow I
mean he hasn't grown in the past several
weeks Warren has only recently
established herself in the top tier and
she has not yet got in the front runner
treatment and she will be tested no
one's gonna give her a free pass to the
nomination
and the last time she had a rough go of
it it was in 2018 with Trump calling her
Pocahontas and she responded with a DNA
test and that did not go well now she
she may have learned since then so I'm
not saying it's a given she's gonna
stumble but she has not been tested and
if she does not whether the test well
both of them could fade and that opens
up the race in a big way for all sorts
of potential possibilities so one kind
of polling question and then we'll move
on to some
the qualitative stuff there are people
who are writing to me all the time
saying okay David I believe Elizabeth
Warren clearly has grown her support
over the last three months that's hard
to deny but you're still seeing polls
where sometimes Biden is +12 and
sometimes Warren is +4 like how
something has to be wrong with some of
these polls right we both can't be
correct i I think the and I have I
haven't gone into a deep dive and good
side well this methodology is excellence
methodologies why and that's what the
difference is yeah is there's a degree
of fluidity here and you know no one we
I think both Biden and Warren have their
diehards I think they both have people
who have are sympathetic to both of them
for different reasons I think people are
conflicted about who's most electable
they're conflicted about exactly how far
can you go policy wise and still be
viable in a general election so you
people might be toggling back and forth
between the two and it's it's not
clearly delineated you know moderates
over here progressives over here and
let's have it out so it's not so
shocking that there is some
inconsistency in the polling but I would
say there is over the scope of the
national polling they are all generally
saying Biden award in the top two
generally speaking Warren having a
slight edge at this moment when we look
at the debates I and the dynamics of the
debates first of all I found them to be
pretty disastrous
I thought debate number three was maybe
the better one in that there was
actually more time spent on one issue
where you could maybe start to figure
out which candidates are able to go
beyond three talking points three bullet
points on a particular issue they were
like 4550 minutes spent on healthcare
etc by and large though I think that
these debates have been terrible
partially because of the moderation and
partially because there's just too many
people on the stage including people who
have no shot at this point what do you
think about the way the debates have
been run and whether they can actually
lead to better understanding of what the
policy knowledge is of the candidates
versus these for the most part
pre-planned gotcha moments well I'm I'm
old enough to
not be waiting not be holding my breath
for debate perfection yes I mean there's
all sorts of questions I think should be
asked I think would get to the heart of
the matter in a lot of ways and they
almost never get asked but having said
that I think we're having a fairly
robust debate about the ideological
direction of the Democratic Party and
the best strategy a visa vie I'm
confronting Trump I mean it's not like
we can't tell the difference between
Warren and Biden here if you don't like
what if you don't like somebody there's
two we you do have other options I mean
you know commas had our moments and Cory
Booker's had his moments and Budaj
engine has moments I mean if you really
like those people you could be
expressing your support for them it's
not like you can't find out who those
people are so I don't think we are
confused about who these candidates are
on what they stand for number one and
number two and this is maybe a bit of a
separate point there are people out
there that always complain all this
takes too long why there's why is there
so much less why can't we be like
Britain and have a two-week election it
is valuable to put these people through
their paces and I mean you you have a
lot of people you got a lot of different
kind of questions to ask live different
potentials for kapha between the
different combos and we're getting
opportunities to see all of that in
action over the course of the last
several months so I don't feel like we
are in a position where we don't know
what's going on like we have a good
sense of where these people are and
where they stand and what they would do
in a general election and and we got
another probably four or five debates to
go until we really make a final decision
yeah we do I guess my concern is on
health care for example it would be
really great to be able to not in like a
talking point who Leon Castro has
something to attack by and we'd like to
really dig into okay let's figure out
what the end point would be of the
approach that Joe Biden is proposing
let's let Bernie talk to Elizabeth
Warren about if she's open to Medicare
for all but not married to it what
specifically would be the alternative
and what would be the effect on cost and
act yeah you don't get that because
you've got ten people on stage and it's
half talking points that that's I guess
what I'm getting at that there's no
question that you can discern
the general difference between where
Biden is and where Warren is you're a
hundred percent right but there are
really important questions that I would
want asked on these issues that we're
just not getting to because 12 people
get a chance to talk right I think we
have learned that there is a real
difference of opinion within the
Democratic Party between a public option
approach and a medicare-for-all approach
yes you go into this people might have
thought everyone's medicare-for-all and
it's not and it's not debate I think
it's been fairly robust and it's
actually had some impact of the numbers
I know you allow your audience might be
very hardcore medicare-for-all and I'm
not saying you are wrong on the
substance by making this point but the
numbers for Medicare of all have gone
down I think it was five points in the
Kaiser tracking poll which asked the
question about public option
single-payer approach every month and I
think that has something to do with the
fact that some bigger big names Biden
Budaj and others have actually had a
pretty forceful pushback on Medicare for
all now I think your point about the
difference between Bernie and Warren on
that score has not been very well
explored and that's not the moderators
fault or the debate structures fault the
two of them have not wanted to go at it
and two of them have been fairly
hesitant to really be pointed towards
each other now maybe that's different
tonight's you we saw Bernie take a you
know a bit of a swipe at Warren but for
being a capitalist on ABC on Sunday yeah
and now that he is clearly behind her he
has a certain incentive to draw those
contrasts and she has not been I mean
her weakest element in her whole
campaign has been answering the question
about wood taxes go up on the middle
class in your health care plan and I
don't think the argument oh well there's
there would be net savings so who cares
who cares the tax question I don't think
that's sufficient I think everybody
knows it's not sufficient LexA for her
tired supporters and I would not be
surprised if both people on her left in
Bernie and on her right press her on
that because people want to see the
numbers and want to see that your
capability at defending the numbers so
there are people on the more moderate
side that would say if you can
make this case maybe your argument is
weak and there people on the Bernie
slide that say hey if you if you are
gonna really make this case maybe you're
not really committed to it and so I
think I would not be surprised if that
mean sir I bet the moderates would try
to draw this out what the candidates
will do I can't predict well I I did a
story early last week where I looked at
the numbers of each candidates second
that the supporters of each candidate's
second choice and what those numbers
suggest to me is that Bernie Sanders is
not really going to be able to make up
the gap by going after Biden
particularly because any damage he does
to Biden based on the morning consult
poll will sort of be evenly split
between him and Elizabeth Warren Biden
voters like Warren slightly more than
they like Bernie so mathematically and
I'm not suggesting this become you know
a poop flinging whatever between Bernie
and Warren but mathematically I don't
know how Bernie recovers without
directly trying to go after Warren
support how do you see that yeah this is
this is a bit of catch-22 for him you
know we haven't seen anyone go out after
war and yet in a very conservative way
of Budaj I just kind of starting to but
everyone's going off to going after
Biden has not reaped the benefits of
that know maybe Biden has been damaged
and so because of it but Kamala
Gillibrand Castro Booker none of those
guys have really benefited by being
pointed in their approach divided and
that has to weigh on birdie is going
after Ward in a very deliberate way it
is upside and downside risk to that but
I think you're also right I mean Warren
has to stumble for Bernie to get back
into the top tier and he has to decide
this he forced that issue does he hope
somebody else forces that issue foreign
policy I feel like has been relatively
absent from the conversation there are
criticisms of what Donald Trump has done
and is doing visibie Russia Ukraine the
Kurds etc and I've identified that
foreign policy is also not Bernie nor
Warren's strongest areas so I'm
wondering where you see the foreign
policy discussion whether you agree that
when it gets into the
details Burnie and Warren don't do
particularly well on foreign policy
you know one of the surprises to me in
this race so far is that Biden has not
been able to play that card because he's
the only person on that stage with
considerable foreign policy experience
right uh and I would have thought that
would have created more of a stature gap
on the debate stage and it's and granted
foreign policy rarely is V issue in a
primary and not to mention to general it
hasn't been the topic of discussion of
most of these debates but it has come up
and when it has come up you know Biden
has not knocked it out of the park in a
way whereas I would say there are points
when it was Hillary versus Bernie when
foreign policy came up she was running
circles around him and that and that not
the reason why he lost my think that
definitely was not a help to him that he
didn't he seemed a bit out of his
element in that in that regard and this
is not to say that it's an ideological
point between being for military force
or being a skeptical military for us I
think fluidity in language depth of
knowledge that was exposed there so so
long as Biden can't show I node for
policy a hundred times better these
other folks beyond that it's kind of a
wash I said something really but who
really bifs in it seems like they really
don't know what they're talking about I
think this is part of by I mean aside
from whether you ideologically like
Biden's foreign policy ideas which is a
different issue this is where I feel
like Biden looks slowed down as you've
talked about the the the sort of optics
of Biden during the debates I would have
imagined that on foreign policy he would
be making it very clear that he has both
the experience and at least well staked
out positions even if you disagree with
them there's sort of a pattern that he
has a worldview into which his policy
ideas fit the fact that he's failed to
do that is to me one of the bigger
signals that he just generally seems
slowed down is the best way that I can
put it I mean III wouldn't prayer in
those terms but I totally get that
people have that takeaway and it the
more people have they take away the
harder it is for him now I saw that
video that the Trump folks push around
what he's talking about how
he twisted the arms in Ukraine yes to
get rid of the prosecutor and of course
that's being used to falsely assert that
he did something untoward uh and when I
look at that video I say he looks strong
he looks sharp he was executing foreign
policy that was directed by both Obama
and backed up by our international
allies and he got done what he what he
said to get done and those are the kind
of anecdotes that he could really use
right in a primary to show I've been
there I've done it and I've made things
happen and it wasn't like that was ten
years ago that video I think was from a
year ago I mean I have a hard time
believing he has slowed down that much
in in a year but the fact remains he
hasn't come across that sharp in these
debates on foreign policy and another
issues by what date do you believe it
will be clear who the nominee is going
to be well that's a little hard to say
right now so if you look at the the
early State polling you CBS you've just
had polls out this weekend where Iowa
was a three-way tie Warren bought Biden
Warren at 22 Bernie at 21 Warren had the
edge in New Hampshire and Biden had the
edge a massive edge in South Carolina
we've seen much less polling in Nevada I
think the last thing I saw me Warren had
a bit of an edge there but whiter was
still in the mix now Iowa and New
Hampshire are almost completely white
very liberal very college-educated
lector it's that is the Elizabeth Warren
sweet spot you know she needs to win at
least one of those two so those are not
great States for Biden if he and right
now the expectation setting a Biden has
been lowered so if he won what are those
two he'd be in fantastic shape
going into South Carolina so if buddy
can win Iowa an eco in South Carolina
showing he could which is a majority
african-american state it is a much more
moderate conservative state electoral II
if he could win there I think he'd be
very poised for a strong Super Tuesday
which is only a few days after South
Carolina and maybe even affect Lear a
pit up at that point if Biden lost Iowa
New Hampshire maybe Nevada too
and then one South Carolina maybe you do
okay on Super Tuesday and you'd have a
bit of a dogfight between him and Warren
or him and Bernie or whoever whoever won
the other contest that could drag out
till the end of the contest which makes
your convention very very dicey because
the super-delegates can't vote on the
first ballot and so you might not have a
majority winner on the first ballot and
the supers come in on the second ballot
and then it's and then it's a brokered
convention it's crazy town
the other option is somebody wins Iowa
and New Hampshire war looks like the
most likely possibility at that point
and then that person runs the table
Super Tuesday then you're basically done
by March that's the sort of John Kerry
model what's different between now and
2004 is South Carolina was not did not
have a standalone date in February in
2004 as South Carolina is Democrat
demographically very distinct from Iowa
New Hampshire a bit less though it with
Nevada so we haven't had a situation
where there that dichotomy presents
itself we don't know exactly that plays
out Super Tuesday and beyond
we will be watching it we know Bill
share will as well he is a contributing
editor to Politico magazine bill always
a pleasure having you on great to be
here thanks so much